welcome back and it is good to be back
uh the media scrutiny around this
morning presenter Phillip Schofield has
been Relentless since he stepped down
more than two weeks ago and sit down
into these with the son on the BBC he
talked about losing everything after
permitting an affair with a young male
colleague
I understand
how Caroline Flack felt
last week
if my
daughters hadn't been there
I wouldn't be here
who knew on the team nobody
well today the key member of his team of
course Holly Willoughby is co-host
return to this morning saying she feels
shaken troubled and let down
imagine that you might have been feeling
a lot like I have
shaken troubled let down worried for the
well-being of people on all sides of
what's been going on and full of
questions
you me and all of us at this morning
gave our love and support to someone who
was not telling the truth
who acted in a way that they themselves
felt that they had to resign from ITV
and step down from a career that they
loved
that is a lot to process
well we all know about stepping down
from jobs we love at ITV but there are
big questions left to answer over this
Scandal or is it time to say enough is
enough do you want to be discuss or
there's a journalist North Jenny
cleanman talk to me is Richard Tice and
Rosanna lock with my my
standard
but not for long like all standing she's
plotting and planning to seize the big
chair
um all right no comment well if you're
not you should be
um what's your taking all this I mean
I've been on for a week reading about it
obviously while lying on a sunbed and it
just reached a crescendo after Schofield
gave his interviews well I looked I've
known him a long time 35 years I wrote a
biography of Philip Schofield literally
in the 90s
um and I looked to the guy and I thought
you are completely broken yeah and and
when someone is in that condition
um even though I felt that his
comparison to Carolina Flack was clumsy
and and he probably shouldn't have said
that he probably meant it he probably
did feel that he was genuinely what's
left I may as well kill myself what do
you think of the whole thing where are
we now with this story I mean the
question that you lined us up with was
should we still care about it is it too
far now I'd say it was too far a week
ago I was saying this when I sat in your
chair this time last week why why do the
public care about this I don't really
give two Hoots about it it's a
television show perhaps a bit reductive
I know it's representative of other
issues in society I know people are
interested but sometimes what's in the
interest of the public isn't what's in
the public interest Richard uh for me
Pez actually he probably was right to
give that interview because it
highlighted to everybody just how he was
feeling and I think that was the moment
at which actually people stopped
attacking him and focused on which I I
think is the right thing to focus on
which is the appalling incompetent
leadership and management of ITV which
is actually a seriously important
the one thing I know for sure a lot of
people at ITV knew about
the rumors about this relationship I
mean everybody knew at ITV right let's
be crystal clear that building was a
buzz with this for about three years
because three years ago the national TV
Awards in the ITV box the young man
concerned in mystery uh confessed his
undying love for Phillip Schofield
everybody knew that so this idea that
the whole management are basically going
we didn't know anything come on
um so that that proves my point that I
know is not true I mean she has presided
over an absolutely catastrophic
performance of this company the shares
are down 60 the dividends down Ford have
said she's being summoned to the select
committee and yet the non-exec directors
they're saying nothing the company said
nothing at the corporate level you know
about this and Dame Carolyn uh God bless
her she was the CEO when I left Good
Morning Britain and they put me in a
position where I had to either apologize
for disbelieving princess Pinocchio or I
had to leave immediately there was no
inquiry for me it was just like you
either now publicly apologize for
disbelieving Meghan markle's lies as it
turned out or you have to leave
immediately so I took the leaving
immediately option uh but what's
fascinating is two days after that after
I'd left
uh the Telegraph newspaper runs a story
that says that Meghan Markle had written
to name Carolyn on the Monday night
before I left on the Tuesday demanding
my head on a plane nobody thought to
mention that to me and had they had done
I wouldn't have been so Hasty in leaving
I would have said I'm not leaving
because some princess tells you to make
me leave right so now to bring it up to
full speed now the same damn Carolyn
McCall has repeatedly said in public
that it had no bearing on the decision
to force me out that is a lie if you're
watching Dame Carolyn that's a lie you
know it's a lie I know it's a lie I
don't want an ongoing fight with ITV I
had a great time at ITV although I
didn't even get a carriage plot when I
left
15 years not even a clock yeah but what
were you I mean what would you do with
the clock if you could work in a factory
somebody gives you a clock right I
didn't even get a thank you right at
least Schofield got 30 seconds of Derma
earlier on a Monday thanking him I've
got nothing I trebled the ratings not
even again so management and Leadership
on a serious Point here's my well this
is a serious point my point really is
my experience of interview management
from the top down is that when it suits
them they'll lie through their back
teeth
secondly that the way they handle Talent
is morally schizophrenic
depending who you are and how important
they think you are to the firmament at
any given moment or how important your
agency is in the case of Phillip
Scoville and so on people like that
Holly Willoughby
um they look at all those things they
make moral judgments based on that kind
of stuff that's where they lose me it's
not consistent there's no concern right
the thing is that will all come out
because there's going to be an inquiry
yeah and I think that's a really good
thing that there is going to be an
inquiry I think if this had happened on
the BBC they would have had to have
called an inquiry a long time earlier I
do think though that there is a there
has been a Feeding Frenzy which has been
spurred by some people who have a
personal beef or maybe jealousy of both
Holly Willoughby and Philip Schofield
that has allowed this story to have a
momentum to go on and on in a Relentless
way that perhaps it doesn't necessarily
again film made quite a lot of enemies
it's not a secret I know quite a few
people well mutual friends who can't
stand it right and they really can't
stand and they made no signal of it
Amanda Holden Eamonn Holmes people like
that they can't stand the guy right
um so that was not a secret uh but I
wrote a piece the chalk and cheese
though peers as you know very well you
know like some people I prefer to be a
pleasant surprise and a bitter
disappointment my my argument about the
ITV data and firmament was that so many
of them were just total effects I wrote
this piece for the sun when this first
broke 10 days ago that the whole thing
is basically fake right they're not real
people a lot of them so they say to your
face I love you I love what you do
you're so fabulous peers and then behind
your back you hear but almost
immediately that they despise you and
can't wait to get your job it's like
it's a whole edification thing is it a
lot of broadcasting like that it is uh
yes yes it is yeah it is and it's a lot
of bosses telling you you're wonderful
you're wondering
you normalize lying and that seems to be
what's happened here is that the lies
went on and on you know if something is
fake it's essentially a lie and that's
going throughout the whole organization
can Holly really not have known
I mean Her speech today reminded me
we've got a bit of it here I think
let's have Holly again
imagine that you might have been feeling
a lot like I have shaken troubled let
down worried for the well-being of
people on all sides of what's been going
on I knew what reminded me of it was
this
Kessler my co-host and partner of 15
years
was fired today for sexual misconduct
stay strong first and foremost I want to
offer our sympathy and support to the
women
we are devastated that this happened on
our watch and our hearts are with you
and to you at home I understand how you
must be feeling because I and the whole
team here at the morning show are
feeling the same way
shock
disappointment
disbelief she's throwing me under the
bus
well
I mean apart for the white dress which
was a good touch the Angelic look uh I I
like Hollywood Beach he's a good friend
of mine I've known for this government a
long time right
um
I like Holly and I don't she's in an
impossible position yeah right she had
to come she had to come back
contractually and do and do what she did
um it's just again I wrote in this piece
like that the the speed with which
people go from Heroes in this game right
where Charities are falling over
themselves to use them to their friend
people they think of their friends at
work no here's a message they're not in
most cases in most cases they will Chuck
you under a bus and into a grave as soon
as look at you while simultaneously
ringing the bosses trying to get your
job right it's just what the nature of
the Beast is it's ruthless it's horrible
and we've seen it laid bare at his worst
but it was out of my question I guess we
started with this didn't we
at some point you've got to you've got
to move on from this unless something
comes out unless the young man concerned
in this story that fully discovered the
affair with as he comes out and
contradicts Philips Global's version of
events or somebody else comes out with
new Revelations what else do people want
Villa Schofield is a broken guy yeah
he's not going to work on television
again almost certainly he's lost
everything in his life yeah uh I don't
know what more the being mob on Twitter
won from Philly to Schofield that he
hasn't already lost and that was what
was so evident from that interview he
was an empty husk and I agree with you
it's clumsy the Caroline Flack
comparison but I remember watching her
documentary where she say she used to go
home after recording her shows and just
read all the tweets and all the comments
and feel empty and emptier and it
reminds you that yeah Showbiz people
presenters they're overpaid it's a
lovely life but they're also human and
it really does kill someone's soul to be
attacked like that mercilessly day after
day but I will say this have the ratings
from this morning ever been higher than
they were this morning I don't know
we'll find out I mean the problem of a
Hollywood be if they were gigantic for
the first half a minute and then plummet
um I mean we'll see look it's not funny
for her she's obviously being a very
tight it's tough it's difficult you're
in an arranged marriage of these
situations I was in one myself suddenly
you're divorced right it's a very you
know
um hard to maintain and when you say
what what what do people want they want
her destroyed they want the show Ax and
there are some people who have you know
like proper professional beefs or who
want the job and are going to keep on
going as soon as you know when the
results of this uh inquiry and I'm not
saying they're all going slightly nuts
but this was the the boss of this
morning uh Martin Brazil uh who's a good
guy uh and from my experience but this
is how he reacted this morning to Sky
News
say what's toxic I've always found toxic
is aubergine do you like aubergine
do you is there a toxic work do you like
aubergine because I don't like aubergine
it's just a personal thing is there a
typical environment at this morning
I've heard of what about
that's a new one somebody mentioned it
might be an emoji a reference I don't
think we really want to go there but um
these situations do send everyone
slightly nuts
this this probably goes quiet until the
inquiry comes out and if the inquiry
finds that actually the management and
the leadership and the board knew about
this then I think the whole pack of
cards comes down and it's a start again
you know the hardest problem for Holly
Willoughby will be who to replace
and with because or else's Anna Ray
she's been through about 15 blokes now
and none of them none of them live up to
me and that's a heartbreaking
heartbreaking moment hard act to follow
yeah
I was trying to say that let's throw
your face are you all like oh really
it's a joke mind you when one of them
was Aleister Campbell you can quite
understand it my God talk about
cratering the audience maybe could you
not do it uh actually because she lead
it and then have a sort of guest host
each week yeah that's what she's doing I
think
it's a fascinating scenario I just think
probably most people in the country now
if not the wider world of just bulb with
it the board short of a new bombshell
move on
don't you think yep yep I think so